everybody welcome to live coding with
Jessie I'm Jessie and today we might not
do what I said I was going to do in the
title of this video so my plan was we
were just gonna start completely from
scratch look up how to do this and do it
but I had a few minutes before the
livestream was going to start and I
couldn't really start anything big so I
thought okay I'll just look up some
documentation on how to do this and I
realized that if we set up what we
wanted to set up which I'll explain in a
minute it might not work out because we
can't use HTTP so let me we'll get into
it and we'll still kind of go through
the process but we need to think about
what effect this is going to have on our
site and if if we really want to set it
up like this so if if you have no idea
what I'm talking about don't worry I
will explain everything I'm gonna give
everybody a few seconds to get in here I
know I started to I announce the stream
a little bit later than normal so in
case somebody's coming in late let me
give them a minute here
hey everyone that's that's here right
now
looks like the notifications did
actually go out for this video let's see
yeah I think I just got one on my phone
okay cool sometimes they don't work when
I started so late so I had a pretty long
meeting earlier in the day but it went
well so that's why I'm streaming a bit
later today and we may have a guest we
may have a guest a little bit later on I
was attempting to recruit someone to
help me with this project with some of
the the data work and so she might stop
by during the stream depending on how
long
the string goes and so that'll be cool
and why my face the light on my face
looks super weird I don't know if it
looks weird to everybody else but let me
turn this light down a little okay I
guess that's kind of better I don't know
it's just looking weird to me okay so
let me let me switch my screen so you
all can see what's happening nope that's
not it
this is it
okay and the light actually looks a bit
better in this shoe so that's nice so
here's what we're working on today let
me make it bigger hopefully come on
bigger
it's a little bit of lag happening so
I'll describe what it is then since it's
the Texas and getting bigger so this is
Google cloud platform storage bucket and
we set that up yesterday yeah we set
this up yesterday we connected it to
WordPress and got that working now I'm
what I'm in the middle of doing there we
go finally got a little bigger what I'm
in the middle of doing is bringing over
all of the files from the old site in
keeping the same file structure and in
terms of files mainly I mean images and
I mean PDFs you know things like that
that would appear on the website the
reason being when we brought over the
markup from the old site it still refers
to a lot of these files in the same
structure so we can take advantage of
that and not have to redo a lot of
things by just using relative URLs in
the markup and then when they come over
when they get to the react components
we'll just prepend the URL of wherever
they're at in this case right now it's
the storage bucket so let me show you
how we've we've done that in react I
think I believe it's here is it
yeah this is it let's make sure we're
up-to-date we'll do a get pool okay and
let's take a component where I know
we've already used this technique just
to show you how this is going to work
let me think the faculty dot JSP
I believe we're using this area okay so
on the faculty is page we're pulling in
data from wordpress with graph QL but
then we're going through that data and
we're manipulating it a bit before we
actually render it to the page
so you see here anywhere that we see a
SRC equals right which is pretty much
for an image we're prepending Franciscan
ddu because right now that actually
works because that site is still
connected to all those files right but
when we switch over and point that URL
to our new site this isn't going to work
anymore so we're going to need to
replace this with that Google Storage
bucket with that URL so the idea that I
I thought would work was okay well let's
do a cname record and let's point it to
that cloud storage bucket and that way
we'll have like a cleaner look and it
all you look like it's coming from the
same place I don't think that's gonna
work though
so let's let's check it out just you to
see how we would would go about doing
this
let me give you I have two examples I
can show you one is the official
documentation and the other one is just
looks like maybe a tutorial someone else
did it's a little bit dated though but I
think it it shows the same point let's
try to go through the official
documentation first if it's a little too
too much to go through then we can
always switch switch back and let's
clean up what we have going on here
and let's pull this over come on here we
go take it and let me put it in there no
oh well so I'll just zoom in quickly on
the part that we need to look at so
basically like right we make the cname
record and then instead of having to
type in this URL we can now type in in
this case they use travel maps at
example.com right and see they can type
that in and then get access to that
image right great that's what I wanted
but if we look at this notes it says you
can use a cname redirect only with HTTP
not with HTTPS to serve your content
through a custom domain over SSL you can
set up a load balancer so it's not that
it's impossible it just requires a load
balancer so we can check it out see how
hard that's going to be maybe we'll
maybe we could do that we'll see if it's
not that hard
might be worth it I just I don't know if
it's worth it to go through the trouble
of setting up a load balancer for this I
don't know let me know what you all
think I'm not sure that that's you know
how many people are even going to
realize what URL the images are coming
from you know really probably only other
devs that open up dev tools
also let me let me start my timer now
that we're gonna start to get into
things here let's start that Pomodoro
timer if I have it there we go I have it
so I'm gonna mainly focus on on what
we're doing here with this cloud storage
bucket for the next twenty five minutes
and then I'm gonna go back to the live
chat after that for about five minutes
and answer any questions that you all
put in there so if you're asking
questions in the live chat please be
patient and I will get to those I'll
keep my eye on the chat though in case
anything pops up that's you know maybe I
should address immediately okay
I lost my there it is okay so let's just
check out this load balancing stuff
let's see if we can do it realistically
I don't I don't really know who would
need a CDN that only uses HTTP I'm right
I mean everyone wants HTTP now it just
doesn't seem that useful to me anyway so
I assume if we have to you to load use
the load balancing to get HTTP there are
going to be other people that want to do
it so you know this this would possibly
be valuable for you all even if I don't
necessarily end up going with this let
me copy and paste this into the live
chat for you all and then that way you
can check it out if you like
all right
I'm just gonna skim over this at first
and see if there's anything it stands
out they're like all we shouldn't do
this alright so we already have a cloud
storage bucket so we don't we don't need
to create one so we've already done all
this
let me know if I have a fan running it's
pretty warm in here so let me know if
it's too noisy and I'll turn it off I
tried to like turn it down as low as
it'll go and kind of point it away so
it's not blowing right on the mic but I
can't really tell with the headphones on
if it's too loud
okay cool so it looks like you'd create
a second bucket to do the load balancing
from
it looks like there was one other thing
it content-based complete the guide for
content-based load-balancing let's check
out that guide as well
if I'm going through this too fast you
know feel free to click on the link or
copy and paste the link from the live
chat you can check it out a little bit
slower so more slowly is that the proper
way to say that instead of slower I
think it's more slowly
okay so from what I'm seeing when you
set up the load balancer like this
basically the load balancer has a static
IP address which obviously if you have
set a copy address right you could point
the domain name to that's what I'm
assuming is what happening so instead of
a cname you could I guess make an a
record use that for your domain I look
I'm gonna give you all a chance do you
think we should go through creating a
load balancers so that we can point a
domain name and use our own domain I
don't know let me know the more I think
about it the more I think maybe it's not
worth the trouble at this point so I'll
give you a minute because of the delay
in the video to let me know we for sure
have a lot of other things that we could
work on so it's not like I'd end the
stream we would just maybe switch over
and work with the my sequel database so
I'm getting a few answers in there I'm
gonna give you all maybe like 20 more
seconds to let me know
all right so here's here's the answers
that I've been so far it looks like yes
do it just walk us through like children
and put the reference material in the
description John says there's always
another way okay so it looks like you
all want I mean I've only heard from a
few people and there's a lot more people
watching so of those who responded it's
you y'all want to do this so I guess we
can we can try it out and let's see how
might not be a bad idea than for me to
move this documentation over to another
screen so that I can reference it and
then we can actually do everything here
on this screen so the first thing we
probably do is let me switch
let me switch over and I'll leave this
open you see this this particular page
is since all this stuff is loading and
I'm streaming at the same time it's it's
going to be impossible to work with this
page so what I want to do is open up
another instance of Google cloud
platform here and I'm gonna switch over
to my account because I don't I don't
want to mess with this in case I decide
not to go with this live and also I
don't want to mess up all the stuff
that's being uploaded right now and
that's it oh it looks like something
must be wrong with free code camp toward
right now but I think they're just
making some updates so okay yeah so if
you haven't struggle getting on right
now sorry about that I don't have
anything to do with the update so I
don't know for sure but usually when
this happens it's not it's not too long
you know things will go back to normal
soon and okay we got a question what are
you uploading I'm uploading data from
the old website why is the current
franciscan DD website so a lot of the
images and PDFs that are available on
the website I'm moving them over to our
new store so like right now they're
hosted on a server on campus here at the
University so we want to host them in
that storage bucket that we set up
yesterday all right so
first things that first thing we need to
do is create a bucket so let's do see
what projects we have have so many
projects I'm not even using let's just
start a new project and create project
let's say just test project there we go
this one I'll just use for whatever
whenever I need to test something no
I'll have a project for that and what
happened where did it go okay it's it's
going it's creating creating test
projects
if you'd like to follow along I'm gonna
paste the URL in there one more time for
anybody that missed it
that's it there now awesome all right so
we're now on test project and
all right and the link that I just gave
you the first step is going to tell you
to complete the guide for a Content for
content based load balancing so let me
put the link in for that as well so that
second link I just paste it in as a link
for that if you've already gone to the
first section you know you could just
click the link that's in there so
all right so we need to go to the
creative virtual machine instance
alright let's check this out this is
cool this will be some new stuff that we
haven't worked on before
I've never gone to that page before let
me see which one this is instances there
we go it's under compute engine we're
going to go to VM instances and we're
gonna go to create instance whoops
alright it's getting ready so we get the
little spinner there so while that gets
ready
I'll check the chat Oh
Anoop thank you I didn't I didn't see
that comment but I knew said the VMS are
found inside compute so thank you for
that I should have just looked over
immediately
hey Nikki's here how's it going yes I'll
take a drink while I'm waiting
it's always important to stay hydrated
right
oh I've never done this before in Google
cloud I didn't realize it would take
this long I'll check in the chat and see
if there's anything else in here that I
missed
love jonesin says can I use this to run
Ubuntu on an old Mac or to run Python I
don't know I mean I guess if you're
creating a VM I mean you can do what you
want with it
so I never thought about doing that but
I guess it will work so I don't I don't
know for sure if it would work but it
seems like it could all right cool so
now we're ready now let's create create
the instance and we're gonna set the
name 2ww and we use we'll just keep the
default zone
let's see machine side you have it's
fine I'll pray keep most of this stuff
defaults you need to find management
disk networking SSH keys there we go
and
we're looking okay startup scripts
filled so we want to insert some code
into the startup script field
let's check this code out so I've to get
update up getting sluggish we're
installing Apache SSL and then
restarting Apache and then echoing HTML
a very small HTML page okay cool
we're gonna leave everything else as
default and we will create that
okay
all right cool so that's there now it
says
insist to do the same thing with video I
guess I'll do it just for the sake of of
being consistent with the instructions
let's do that
so let's create another instance and
name this for those of you that are
joining us recently in order to create a
cname record no no in order to create a
custom domain name for our cloud bucket
that actually uses HTTP you have to
setup load balancing so that's why we're
setting up this load balancing stuff
first in order to make that work okay
and we're gonna put in a custom startup
script in here that's almost identical
to the other one but it just has some
different data here in the index page
and let's create that now we're gonna
make a firewall rule to allow traffic to
our VMs so let's go to firewalls page
which let's see how we're gonna get
there
you know I saw firewall area firewalls
visit the Ray page
I don't think so those firewalls I need
to find firewall rules there we go
firewall rules
actually do my it alright I said that
five minutes in about five minutes I'm
gonna go back to the live chat answer
some questions so if you have any
questions please put them in the live
chat sometime within the next five
minutes okay so here's our firewall
rules page we need to create a rule and
we're gonna name it ww firewall and
let's set the network's default and our
source filter we're gonna allow sources
from
from any source so basically to do that
we're going to do 0.0.0.0 slash zero
okay and let's set our our ports and
we'll go for right now let's do port 80
and 443 port 80 is your normal HTTP port
port 443 is your HTTP port since we're
just testing this out I'm fine with
allowing both but in production
environment I'd be more comfortable if I
just ran port 443 and you know high port
80 disabled okay and one more target
tags here
let's do HTTP tag and then we're gonna
do HTTP tag since we're going both will
put both in there and now let's creates
as soon as the spinners done we go onto
the next step
yay all right cool so let's go back to
our VM whoops
know what happened I'm gonna refresh cuz
it just froze up go back to the menu
there we go VM instances
okay external IP let's check this out so
we're going to copy the IP and paste the
IP
see what happens
so we should see that those very tiny
little HTML files that were there that's
that's which should come up so I don't
know how long it's supposed to take
let's click the other one to just get it
started since it seems to be taking so
long
let's try the HTTP explicitly
you're not working okay all right
why is it not working open in browser
window alright let's try that let's
allow pop-ups and try this again opening
rather
all right my time we did go off so let
me set a short break here okay
so it did allow me to go in here so I
thought that I would actually see the
HTML maybe I'm not supposed to see that
maybe that's not how it was set up it's
not exactly clear mmm all right well let
me go back to the chat I'm gonna scroll
up make sure I don't miss any questions
and go through as many questions as I
can in five minutes
not really a lot of questions so trying
to find some
John asks if the Google cloud platform
is feasible for small apps it I've never
tried out for small apps but it seems
like a lot of the pricing is based on
usage it's all based on usage so it
might it might be affordable I never
really tried to figure out how much it
would be for something small so I don't
know if it would be cheaper to go with
you know a different service that
focuses more on small things I don't
know is anybody does anybody ever use
use it in that way I mean it seems like
it's there's a lot more features than
you would normally need for something
small so if in terms of complexity you
know they're definitely you're less
complex ways of doing it but in terms of
costs I'm not really sure what would be
cheaper this is what what language is
more future-proof I'm trying to figure
out which language to learn first Thanks
oh well it's hard to tell the future
right if you're if you're going by
trends I mean realistically javascript
has been gaining ground for a long time
now more and more things are being built
with JavaScript that couldn't be built
with JavaScript before right like when
when I was in high school and just
learning how to do websites you couldn't
do JavaScript on the server right that
didn't exist and what you could do with
javascript was actually pretty limited
[Music]
now you can do a lot I mean you you do
everything you wanted anything that you
can do normally in a programming
language you could probably find a way
to do it with JavaScript so just the
growth there makes me think that if that
trend continues it's it's gonna be you
know continue to be one of the main
languages
but there are other languages that are
so entrenched in a lot of big companies
in the in the code bases for these huge
companies that they're not going to go
away anytime soon so like there's so
much stuff built with Java Python PHP
like those big languages like there if
they ever go away it's it's gonna take a
long long time I mean just consider it
like there are still companies that use
COBOL right which is an ancient by
computer standards it's it's ancient but
you know there are there are code bases
out there that change infrequently but
they still need people to maintain them
so I wouldn't worry so much about your
language not being around in the future
as long as you pick a language that is
your kind of one of the top languages
you're safe
if you go with some really obscure
language that's not used very much right
now that could potentially die out and
nobody will use it right so if if you're
I think probably like what are the top
like I mentioned Java JavaScript Python
PHP this is not in any particular order
Python PHP those those are your big ones
if I'm leaving one out let me know but
oh I'm forgetting like c-sharp I mean
there is still even stuff down in C++
right so but I'm gonna say this is my
five that I'm gonna say are probably
gonna be around for a long time c-sharp
Java JavaScript Python PHP and you pick
any one of those you probably don't have
to worry about you know that language
not being used anymore for a long time
so I mean as for smaller languages
there's a ton of small languages there's
I'm sure there's lots of smaller that
computer languages that are used that
I've never been heard of right I
probably never hear
that's not necessarily a good thing if
you're trying to get a job right there's
just not a lot of jobs out there so
anyway I know starting out that's like a
huge question and a source of anxiety
like what should I pick but it's always
easier to learn your second computer
language because you have the concepts
down so even if you decide later on you
don't really like the one that you chose
to learn you know don't worry about it
too much you can always switch it'll be
a little more work but not quite as much
work as learning it you know the first
time all right and my timers up so we're
gonna do another Pomodoro session and
then I'll come back and I see there are
some more discussion going on there so
I'll check that out after I come back
so we'll probably just end up doing one
more session and then I'll do some more
questions and then we'll finish up for
today
oops for my back here
all right well now that I'm in here
let's just look around - we have hmm
okay it looks like we're running Apache
right based on the code that we the
startup code we're running Apache so we
should have we're gonna go into that
whoops this is probably really small I'm
sorry everyone let me try to make this
bigger so this is this is all that I've
done I just backed out two directories
from my default directory that I was in
so and then I went into the there or var
directory and the www which is your
default directory for serving websites
and Apache and so now I'm just listing
and that's our index.html file that I
was thinking that we'd see if we
actually went here whoops so we can see
like obviously things are there there is
stuff there the stuff that we did worked
I guess we can verify that that that
step did work if we go in I'm assuming
Nano is here
I know index and yep there it is so
there's that HTML that we had there I'm
gonna get out I don't want to edit that
okay so that's that's there I'm just
gonna leave for now hopefully I don't
need to go back in pick right away let's
see
all right so now we need to make a an IP
address so we're gonna go to the
external IP addresses page which is
there we go
external IP addresses and let's reserve
a static address and the name I'm just
going with the name from the tutorial
we're gonna go with the ipv4 and we want
it to be global and so play don't get
charged too much for all this I'm gonna
cancel at all as soon as I'm done and
hey now's a great time to bring up my
page here on page if you'd like to help
support my streams check out my patreon
face and help me out when I do stuff
like this and just not sure how much I'm
gonna get charged for all this
experimentation
all right let's create an instance group
now and where do I go for that let me
see
instance group I'm going to create a new
one
I just got a message from work I need to
answer this hold on one second
okay all right so you can create one
let's set the name to resources and
we're gonna set the zone to us central
1b I'm not really sure why
where you taking that particular zone
the instructions here don't really say
so if you want to follow along and see
if two instructions yourself click on
that link that I put in the live chat a
little earlier we're gonna set the group
type to unmanaged instant group instance
group and let's see for VM instance
unmanaged
hmm it says no available instances
yeah that must have been a mistake in
the documentation because obviously we
didn't make instances in that particular
zone so let's WW and so that's going to
be our instance and then
we're gonna create another instance
group for our other 4ww video
okay create
and let's just go back in create another
one and this will be whoops let's call
it video via resources unmanaged and
let's video create that
see
all right cool those are finished
all right sorry I lost my place I was
looking ahead and lost my place in the
documentation now I'm back let's set up
we're going to set up a lot of stuff so
now we're gonna name our load balancers
so let's go to our load balancing page
which where did we set that up this is
freezing up somewhat frequently all
right so
on our load balancing pages
there we go load balancing and
with other balancers under HTTP load
balancing click start configuration
you're saying
hmm
I'm not getting the same maybe I'll kick
click create okay I had to click create
first that was the problem
HTTP load balancing let's start and
let's name it web map and back-end
let's say create a back-end service
let's name it web map back in service
alright let's say I'm just gonna leave
since it'll be faster I'm gonna leave
that as default instance group www
resources 480
let's do
let's shake I never set up a health
shake
alright let's set up a basic health
check
HTTP basic check and I'll just leave
everything default okay
okay
all right so thing we're good and we'll
just repeat that for video
the SMS the video resources and health
check this yeah let's create the health
check
alright let's create that okay
all right let's go to host empath rules
[Music]
okay so let's go is
[Music]
my house and then we're gonna set our
past to video and video there we go
okay wonderful
lastly front end and
let's say
HTTP content rule and we're just going
to do HTTP to save some time normally
you want to go with HTTPS though IP
here we go
and good
if you six
school is HTTP content ipv6
I thought early in the documentation we
didn't do an ipv6
and let's review and finalize and click
create
I just have to wait so this is done
the good news is it seems like we're
almost done
I'll check the chat while this little
spinner is spinning see hey Phoenix is
here how's it going
what the specified IP address is in use
and would result in a conflict involve a
you for resource IP yes
okay
she's not gonna let me edit this
a year ago edits
hmm well everybody I think I just failed
I think I just failed pretty bad so
I'm not sure I even remember where I put
in that IP and how far back in the
process that was
it was that when we went to set up a
static IP
all right so let me I don't really have
enough time to go back and fix that so
let me say assuming that would have
warts we would go back to these original
directions that we started started that
you would if you haven't already created
a bucket you'd create your bucket and
then you go back to the load balancing
page you'd go to the backend
configuration and I I think you would
just add your static bucket you would
add the back end for your static bucket
and for your host and path rules you
would just add so we had already added
that path for video we would do the same
thing in there with static and then we
would just set up our addresses to get
to that static bucket where we put in
our external address so the rest of the
steps seem really simple and
straightforward so we went through the
hardest part and we went through most of
it at some point though I messed up I
suppose so
yeah so I don't have time to fix that
and I'm not really sure so IP address
already in use okay so yeah I don't know
I don't know what happened with that but
if you wanted to set up load balancing
for your buckets so that you could use a
so you could have a static IP address
that they
you could use and in point in a record
to that to have your custom domain
that's how you would do it that's a lot
of steps so I guess it's something to
consider in my case I think I'm not
gonna do it I think I'm just gonna stick
with the URL that is the default that
Google gives me I I don't think I don't
really think it's worth me going through
all these steps and paying all the extra
money for those extra for all the apps
are set up just to be able to do that if
it happens at some point in the future
that I find some reason why I should do
it like that then I will and at least
we've gone through it once and I know
what's involved but I mean it was it was
cool to go through and find out more of
Google cloud platform because there's
still a lot of it that I've never even
seen and never used so that was kind of
cool hopefully this this was helpful to
somebody out there to go through some of
this and I guess the last thing I'm
gonna do is make sure I'm not gonna get
billed for any of this so where's my
billing can I turn it off for this
project test project disable billing yep
there we go and I do want to disable for
this as well
I'm gonna leave that here for now but at
some point I need to move that on to the
university account all right cool so
hopefully I don't get billed at all for
that small amount that I used but you
never know if I do get billed at all
it'll probably be very very minimal so
I'm not too worried about it
all right I'm gonna now go to the live
chat and I will I'm sorry I'm still
trying to chat with my my coworker here
and figure figure this out
there's something going on with one of
the links on the main website we're
trying to figure it out
okay
it looks like he found it so that's good
all right let me so if you have any
questions right now please put them in
the chat now I'm gonna answer all the
questions that I can
okay Sabah Neffs are you hosting
wordpress as well on a google virtual
machine no I'm actually not so I'm I
would like to host WordPress with next
and that's a service from site it's the
same company that makes next jazz I'm
sorry do this I think I said that wrong
I want a host WordPress with now which
is from the same company that does next
potentially we could host it on on a VM
as well so right now I have it running
on digital ocean but so if for some
reason it doesn't work out using now
it'll probably just stay on digital
ocean but I'm pretty sure that it it can
work I've successfully tested it I just
want to make sure that it's it works as
well and as easy as I expect it to Jacob
says Google Cloud versus digital ocean
Sobhan says I think digital ocean is
more affordable just my opinion honestly
for me I'm I'm not 100% sure about the
price I've never really looked into it
like that deeply but digital ocean is
easier and in my opinion digital ocean
is easier although you know I've worked
more with digital ocean so it may just
seem easier to me there Google Cloud
just has so much stuff going on it can
be overwhelming there's a lot so that's
good because you know potentially you
can add in all these extra services as
you as you grow you know as your app
grows and they're all right there so I
mean there's a benefit to that
complexity if you think that you'd need
it later on
Nikki says there's that rule from
someone on Twitter every program that
can be written in JavaScript will
eventually be written in JavaScript yeah
I can't remember who said that
originally but I do hear that repeated
from time to time
my dad's just saying I'm hearing loads
of great things about digital ocean and
JavaScript is popping up everywhere for
full-stack everything yeah for sure for
sure
I do like digital ocean I've used it I'm
hosting a lot of stuff there right now
so I like it in JavaScript
I mean I've used I've done some
workshops where we used up we've used
JavaScript to create Internet of Things
stuff which is so cool right made like a
little a little car that you could
control through like I don't remember if
we did Wi-Fi or Bluetooth but you can
control it through your computer
keyboard right this it was cool and it
was a node J s a program that was
running it so I mean that that's just
cool I've seen people on YouTube do
machine learning with JavaScript there's
just there's not an area right now where
something's happening with programming
that there's not a way to do it in
JavaScript that was a really confusing
way to say it
let me say it differently said if
there's something happening within the
programming world right now you can do
algebra skills I think that's a better
way this is better way to do it
is JavaScript always the best option I
don't know probably not but is it an
option yeah
hey I think this is our guest
now that's cool I just that's how you go
over there alright so I am on YouTube
let me let's expand this screen a bit
I'm gonna show more of his being doodle
that mean
yeah that's the camera I can I need to
change my settings real quick I have my
camera zoomed in so I'm gonna change it
a bit so it's just a little bit a little
bit wider so let's I'm gonna zoom it all
the way out
alright alright cool this way I cool
Joonas AI hello world alright so
hopefully you'll be helping me with some
data so I I just happened to run into
her in the the office kitchen and we
started talking about websites and so
she has some experience with websites so
she was a student here took a web web
design course and also had a job where
she was stuck trying to make the best of
a terrible website so as she was telling
me all of her experience with this
website I was like wow you're already a
web developer like this is what we deal
with right like we have problems and we
figure out how to solve the problems and
so she was saying that she's she's
looking for a job and so I said hey I'm
I'm offering its up so yeah so we got to
work out the details but hopefully
she'll be she'll be helping out so you
might see her on a future stream if you
want alright cool so at this point in
the show is just doing some question and
answer okay cool yeah alright so this is
the last thing I do so after this will
be done then I can show you some some
other stuff okay all right so I lost my
place let me find it
okay so Nikki that quote that we just
said about everything that can be
programmed in JavaScript will eventually
be programmed in JavaScript it was from
the co-founder of Stack Exchange so
thanks for that Nikki and alright
sapiens says the node also offers a
cheap virtual machine but I prefer a
digital ocean okay cool yeah I've done
some stuff with Lenovo only like I've
inherited the node based site so I
haven't really done anything like from
scratch John Hanson says I thought
firebase firestore was free maybe free
is in Google Maps API yeah a lot of
Google stuff has like a free tier that's
it's limited it's good for testing
things and maybe doing like I don't
small project small apps so I'm assuming
it's like that for firebase as well
Matt Dutchess says Heroku has a free
package yeah I think they do - I need to
check in to Heroku because I let one of
the conference's I was at I got like a
card that with a code on it that I could
use to get a bunch of free free Dino
minutes or hours over on on Heroku
michael says so first time context in
case you weren't watching earlier when I
was setting everything up with the
Google cloud platform I said I'm not
sure how much they're gonna charge me
for this because we were just
experimenting and Michael says I don't
think I've used the phrase I'm not sure
how much I'm going to get charged for
this experimentation since I went to
Mardi Gras in New Orleans
so hopefully you didn't get charged too
much for that Michael
I've never been to Mardi Gras that would
would be cool and I'm hoping I don't get
charged too much either
I just resized my font now I'm lost
again on the live chat
okay cool honey
Martin asks the server this architecture
mean using pre-built api's like firebase
or doesn't mean something totally
different I mean you can do there's a
lot of different options but yeah but
like essentially serverless this is not
an official definition but like you're
always gonna have a server it's just is
that gonna be your server somebody
else's and are you going to maintain
that server so serverless is gonna allow
you to just like send off your code have
it run you don't have to worry about any
server maintenance at all so however you
set that up you know it just it depends
depends on what you're doing
what does AWS has lambda I think I'm not
sure what the equivalent is called in in
Google or Microsoft Azure but I don't
know that's my take on on server list
though
and Nikki and Michael are talking about
Lil Wayne songs or little John song so
I'm not I don't I was don't know what's
going on on that side conversation
it's fun since I need someone with
Jessie's drinking mind-altering in order
to heavily focus energy okay so I was
just drinking water during the stream
but I did have G fuel beforehand so once
again if anybody from G fuel is watching
I'm open first launcher [ __ ]
I got v G fuel sponsorship even if you
just send me some G foo every month I'd
be happy with that Jacob says Ola from
Steubenville Ohio Jacob are you into
voodo right now let me know
Oh Nietzsche said so at the end whenever
my my IP address wouldn't work and it
just it completely failed Nikki had an
idea that I would open that terminal
session and I may not have ever closed
it I closed the window but I didn't like
exited from the terminal so that could
have been the cause of the error so
that's a good idea I didn't even think
of that at all
Powell says how often do you record live
coding I try to do five days a week but
often times I don't get five days a week
just because of meetings and things so I
mean usually it ends up being more like
three three days a week worlds Asif
digitalocean is easy to use and easy to
see costs yeah for sure
the pricing on digital ocean is really
upfront
totally totally easy to figure out what
your costs are going to be
michael says what main package would you
need to do machine learning with Jas I
can't what is called I mean there's more
than one I can't remember check out the
channel is a learn code dot Academy is
the channel will stern does that YouTube
channel one of his recent videos I think
his last two videos that he put out was
going machine learning with JavaScript
so check those videos out they're pretty
short I think maybe ten minutes each or
so that'll give you at least one way to
do it and if you can't find that channel
go to my youtube channel the links in
the description and I link to his
channel from my my home page
oh okay Nikki says there's a tensorflow
j/s now okay cool so check out sensor
flow that's not the one that will Stern
was using in his videos but tensor flow
is really well known so if they have a
JavaScript library now I'm assuming that
it's pretty good
you never mentioned your name do you
need I'm sorry guys my name is Haley
alright so no I know I just a lie no no
it's just a jle why AJ led basic alright
cool so Haley so you'd said John says
new John Murphy says future show live
coding with Jessie and Haley sorry I
didn't introduce you that's it's okay I
never got on the stream before guys so
sorry not used to it
certain hollows has given me free Google
credit can I do that do they have a
referrer program if anyway I do have
referral codes for several other things
so like if if anybody's interested I
could I could give you my referral codes
for stuff so you know usually you end up
getting some something free
all right looks like I'm down to the
last question so unless somebody puts a
question in there in the next minute
we'll finish things up so world says
have you ever had issues and react with
sizing several components to fit the
viewport I've wrapped them but the
bottom component never fits I don't know
it's kind of hard to say worlds if you
have the code on github let me know you
can send me a DM on Twitter and I could
check it out more
I kind of have to see the code because
I'm assuming that that's more of a CSS
issue and not necessarily a react issue
so I could I could probably check it out
though and and give you point at least
point you in the right direction now
that just says build a blog or a site to
advertise your affiliate links I've been
thinking about doing that my personal
website is so old I haven't updated it
in years like I don't know like three or
four years so I need to just change it
and put my links on there and an update
with stuff that I've actually done
within the last three years but I think
that's a good idea John Murphy says do
you use SSH keys or just password for
root on digitalocean I always use SSH
keys I usually try to disable root user
and disable passwords completely just go
with SSH that's a lot more secure
although I do make sure I have more than
one computer that has SSH keys for it
michael says she knows how to do product
mist twist I've never heard of that it's
the big paper in which I wouldn't be
drinking but it was the only kind of my
sister could show you sponsorship for
that Nina as well right when I said
we're out with the last question
everybody started asking questions
alright so Nina says I learned
JavaScript's react Redux what is next I
would say Lunas next is build some
awesome stuff you definitely know I mean
maybe learn some graph QL so that you
can pull some data into your react
applications if you want to move into
back-end stuff then learn some node I
mean otherwise I mean if you know
JavaScript react and redux you you know
you're definitely in a good position to
make some awesome things
I'm had Duchess says it's okay Avenue
built mine
yeah I'm terrible about working on my
own website
you
all right I'm officially at the end of
the chat now so thank you all so much
for watching sorry I didn't get what we
were working on to work almost we were
so close if anybody gets it to work let
me know if you try to do this on your
own
I'd like to know like does it work is it
awesome yeah so I should be back
tomorrow see I have meetings in the
morning tomorrow so it'll probably be
another afternoon stream I'll be back in
the office yeah so anyway thanks again
and until tomorrow have a great day guys